[Music]
so good to see you it yes I'm right you
know we're all very happy for you
because we've known you a long time
you've always been a hilarious comedian
and now you're showing up in all these
big films you're getting a lot of
critical acclaim you're in young adult
now you're making a movie with Ben
Stiller yeah we start shooting next week
yeah it's so your careers it's really
it's really going places you must you
must be happy at long last you must be
happy
that's what class it's you know it was
really it's really weird I yes I'm very
I'm very grateful and very happy for
what is going on but at the same time I
still have that weird depression and it
now it's not even about anything
specific it's almost like the depression
is just this friend that I have to hang
out with every now and then right to
make him like here's how here's how
we're did is now the other day I was in
the suit the supermarket near where I
live I'm in the frozen food aisle and
I'm looking at this shelf of Lean
Cuisines I'm just looking at all these
Lean Cuisines I'm not thinking of
anything and then out of nowhere on the
sound system Toto's Africa started
playing that song Africa and I don't
know what it was I became immediately
and wasn't even in a sad way I became
blissfully suicidal like I could have
just immediately when I'm telling you if
I'd had a gun I wouldn't have even
thought twice looking on Oh type penis
bows and if anyone in here because there
is something so instantly depressing
about looking at a wall of Lean Cuisines
and Toto's Africa's playing I knew the
only one in a supermarket I almost feel
like if someone had been at the end of
the aisle and see me blow blow my brains
out and the cops are coming on hey what
happened they went oh well he was
looking at this Lean Cuisine and then
Toto's and the company yeah I know
exactly what I got
that makes absolute sense that he would
yeah frozen food Toto's Africa got it
case closed absolutely close did you
what Lean Cuisine did you end up you did
you end up going with a particular one
well here's what's really sad I ended up
buying a Lean Cuisine first I saw one
that I wanted which is the Thai peanut
noodles one and but I took it out and I
look at the back instructions and it
says cut a slit in the top put it the
microwave for two and a half minutes
then remove and then open the plastic
and stir it and when I saw that I went
I'm I don't have time for that I bought
the macaroni and beef one which is you
just flip the top and put it in for you
and that's it like that the second step
made me go I'm not Emeril here I'm not
like making a I just wanted to put it in
once hit three minutes
and that's it like that's how for some
reason that so depressed it was well
okay
now you mentioned Toto in the sense
you're a bit of a music snob okay listen
I'm not there's music I don't listen to
alright especially when I'm near Lean
Cuisines but but when I was I'm now at
that age where when I was young if I
didn't like music I had to let you know
not only do I not like it but it's evil
like I had I would lecture people and go
like Nickelback and Creed those guys
suck the only reason they're singing
that crappy music is to get money and
that's the only reason and I was so
adamant and I really wished there have
been someone there to go yes Patton that
is why they are doing that to get and
then that which they gon do you know
what people do to get money and this
planet they do horrible things they kill
people they take over countries and the
guy in Nickelback said you know I would
like to also have that amount of money
in my life
now I could go kill a continent full of
people or I could go
[Applause]
it was a humane decision it makes him
kind of heroic yeah
[Laughter]